It was the financial scandal of the century.
One of the most respected figures on wall street,
a man who was considered to have the investment mid touch had not actually
invested a dime in the past 15 years. Instead,
it'd been running the largest Ponzi scheme in all of history in today's
biographics.
We take a look at the stunning rise and the cataclysmic fall of Bernie
Madoff.
Bernard Lawrence Madoff was born on April the twenty,
nineteen thirty eight in Queens, New York, his parents,
Ralph and Sylvia were the children of east European Jews who had fled to America
in the early 19 hundreds to escape th and antisemitism.
The couple were married in 1932 at the height of the great depression.
Ralph had a succession of jobs,
including as an assistant manager at a wholesale jewelry store.
The family managed to move from the Bronx to the more up markets bemans avenue
in Brooklyn. By the time that their second child Bernard was born older,
sister Sandra had been born in 1934 with brother Peter following in
1945 in 1946, the Madoffs purchased their first home,
a modest two story red brick with a small garage location in Laurelton New York.
This was a pretty middle class suburban neighborhood with treeline street.
The Madoffs were remembered by neighbors as a close and loving family.
And Bernie as a normal kid who enjoyed playing stickball and riding his bicycle
around the neighborhood. Bernie began his schooling in 1946.
He seemed to be a fairly popular students, but not a standout one.
In many respects academically, he was pretty average best on the sports field.
He was even worse. Not did he have any success with the girls?
He had a crush in a girl named Elsa Lipson and made some muddled efforts to win
her over. However, she chose his best friends, which cut Bernie rather deeply.
Bernie did end up with a girlfriend during his middle school years,
a girl by the name of Marcia Mendelson, however,
who was constantly falling short of his peers, academically fact,
which negatively affected his self confidence. Marcia later recalled.
I remember he was always disappointed getting his grades because he didn't make
the honor society. He wanted to be in the honor classes.
We all knew he was always the struggler.
Marcia decided to end the relationship because she didn't think that Bernie was
smart enough for her.
His high school years were happier for Bernie than his primary school
experience. He joined the swimming team.
Finally discovering something physical that he was actually good at.
He took a couple of part-time jobs.
One was as a lifeguard at the beach during the summer months while the other was
as a laborer installing sprinkler systems in people's yards,
the combined incomes began to nicely build his bank account.
Bernie's self-confidence was lifted through his acceptances. One of the guys,
he be a well adjusted, happy young teen though. He still struggled academically,
but he was also developing a knack for deception.
On one occasion in English class,
each student was to deliver an oral book report.
Bernie hadn't even opened the first page of his book.
When it came time for him to address the class,
he rose and told the class that his book was called hunting and fishing by Peter
Gunn. He then went on to make up names, dates,
and details of a book that never actually existed.
The teacher missed the pun and the reference, the popular TV,
detective Peter Gunn.
And she gave him a high commentation while it was pretty clear to anyone who
bothered to look that Bernie Madoff wasn't book smart.
He did have an innate smartness that alluded all of his peers and that smartness
it revolved around the ability to make money while his bank account swells and
those of his smarter classmates didn't.
He came to realize that money could be the thing that brought him fulfillment
during his first year at Rockaway high,
Bernie came across a popular outgoing girl by the name of Ruth APEN.
Her personality was the mirror opposite to his,
but they soon became inseparable, not just at school,
but also at each other's houses.
Benny graduated from far Rockaway high school in 1956,
while the rest of his classmates, they headed off to Harvard or Yale.
He traveled south to enroll of the university of Alabama,
even though he told his friends that he had been recruited to the university
swim team.
It escapes nobody's attention that getting into this university was much easier
than any of the colleges up north, but Bernie didn't stay in Alabama for long.
He was just simply too far away from his beloved Ruthie back in New York.
So he enrolled at Hofstra college on long islands where he studied political
science
Bernie's father. Ralph began dabbling in the stock market in the mid 1950s.
And it was from him that Bernie's fascination with the subject began during his
first year at Hofstra. He was already working as a stock broker though,
not holding a broker's license.
His father was also apparently trading illegally.
Although his mother Sylvia had two security company is registered to our name.
When the securities and exchange commission came down on her in 1963 for not
filing financial statements, she closed down both businesses.
This was just one of a slew of financial TAs that plagued the Madoff family in
the 1960s.
Ralph was involved in a number of businesses with others that fell apart on one
occasion and $9,000 li was place down the house after which Ralph transferred
the title of the home to his wife to avoid not losing it. In 1959,
Bernie and Ruth got married the following year.
He graduated from Hofstra college with a bachelor's degree in political science.
They moved into a one bedroom apartment in Bayside, Queens,
Bernie enlisted in the us army reserves in order to avoid the draft.
He was given a com as a second lieutenants and designed to the headquarters of
the first army based on governor's island in New York Harbor,
the duties were light, mostly involving administration.
Bernie served for the next three and a half years, mainly on the weekends
After graduating from Hofstra at Bernie enrolled at the Brooklyn law school.
But this effort, it petered out within a year and he dropped out.
He has with the full backing of his wife,
made the faithful decision to go out on his own and pursue his passion.
At the age of 22, he registered his business.
Bernard L Madoff invest securities Madoff past the general securities
representative exam, allowing him to get a stock broker's license.
On the same day,
he took the far more difficult general securities principal exam,
and he also passed this.
So in one day he gains the right to not only operate as a stock broker,
but to run his own brokerage firm.
Bernie LASIK could claims that he began the business with the aid of a $50,000
loan from his father-in-law Saul.
APEN Saul also provided space in his Manhattan accounting firm Meza base of
operations,
Bernie specialized in buying and selling stocks that were too low for the big
firms to worry about.
This meant that he was dealing with very minor Rob brand new companies.
These were known as penny stocks, the work involved hours,
cold calls and little reward. After a few months,
Bernie added a second arm to the business investing on behalf of individuals.
Bernie's first personal investment clients was a dress maker by the name of Carl
Shapiro.
He handed the newbie investor a sum of a hundred thousand dollars to invest on
his behalf. Bernie grew this funds impressively on the two,
developed a business really that would make them both fabulously wealthy on the
basis of this success. Bernie set his sites higher.
He designed an investment concept based on people who he called feeders,
who would find investors to bring in cash.
He would then invest and grow that cash.
Keep a portion and disperse the rest back to the investor. As feeders,
Bernie turned to the other people in his immediate business in environment,
his father-in-law so, and to young accountants who worked for him.
The problem was that none of these three were registered stock brokers,
which made their involvement illegal over the next three years,
his three feeders brought millions of dollars in investment finance to Bernie.
The moment pop investors were all making money.
So everyone was very happy in just one deal. In the late 1960s,
Bernie made a commission of $60,000 on the sale of a hundred thousand shares
with the incredible success of the business.
Bernie and Ruthie were able to move to suburban long island in 1966,
by then they had a two year old named mark and Ruthie was pregnant with their
second child. Andrew
Around 1970, Bernie also moved his business.
He relocated to 40 exchange place,
just one block from the New York stock exchange.
Bernie quickly embraced computer technology,
outfitting his new office with the latest equipments.
He also pushed the Cincinnati stock exchange to host a third market,
getting them a quarter of a million dollars to upgrade their computer system.
The results of this initiative was the national association of securities
dealers, automated quotations, or the NASDAQ.
The NASDAQ changed the game,
allowing brokers to see quotes from other traders all over the world Madoff's
business, which had already been flying high. It now hit the stratosphere.
He quickly established a reputation as the wizard of wall street over the next
20 years, he served in various capacities in the national of securities dealers,
which was a self-regulatory body. As the 1980s drew to a close,
Bernie was making north of a hundred million a year in 1990.
He served as chairman of the NASDAQ repeating this in 91 and 93.
Okay. A little break here. And there is some good news, Bernie Madoff.
He was only really interested in your money and not in your data,
but the internet is full of crooks.
He will steal your data and use that data to extract money in a variety of
nefarious ways. And that's why just before we get into the Ponzi scheme,
the Bernie Madoff is famous for,
I want to tell you about the Nord VPN today's sponsor. So often in the news,
we hear about the latest data hack or data breach. These are not good things,
but the good news is that you can protect yourself by using a VPN and Nord VPN
is absolutely the way you should be doing that.
If you've ever been in a caffeine,
you are using the public wifi and there's lots of people around and you're just
like, ah, should I be this? The answer is you shouldn't,
unless you're using a VPN.
And definitely don't go in and check your internet banking or use your PayPal or
anything like that, unless you fire up Nord VPN first. Also,
if you're in another country and you wanna watch content,
that's usually only available in your home country,
whether that's videos or news or anything like that,
you can definitely do with Nord VPN.
And also if you've used VPNs in the past and thought, oh yeah, it was fine,
but they were really slow. You don't have to worry about that with Nord VPN,
you can watch video. It's a breeze it's super fast.
You never have to worry about that spinning pin wheel,
waiting for the videos to load. Again, also, it works in all of your devices,
Android Chrome windows, Linux,
and you can use it on six device prices with just one account.
You don't have to pay extra. Also Nord VPN is based in Panama.
So unlike companies based in the EU or the us,
they don't have to keep any logs at all. Obviously fantastic for your privacy.
So look,
Nord VPN are offering you as a view us 75% off three year plans,
plus a month for free, just in case that 75% wasn't enough.
All you have to do is go to Nord, vpn.com/biographics,
or click the link in the description below and doing that these videos are long.
We make four of them a week.
It is sponsors like Nord VPN that really do make this possible.
And they'll keep supporting this show.
If you go through that link and check them out. So just go to Nord,
vpn.com/by biographics that help support the show.
And let's get into that Ponzi scheme. Shall we?
According to Bernie's own court testimony, he began his Ponzi scheme in 1991.
However many people believed that it had been doing it for a long time.
Before that he couldn't explain why,
why he did it as he was amazingly successful in his legitimate business
activities.
He stated I had more than enough money to support my lifestyle and my family's
lifestyle. I didn't need to do this for that.
I don't know why the original Ponzi scheme was named for Charles Ponzi,
who promised returns a 50% on a 90 day investment in the 1920s,
the scheme you income from new investors to pay promised interest rates to the
original investors.
The word of these fabulous returns quickly spreads attracting new investment.
And the scheme keeps perpetuating itself. Of course,
the person behind the scheme breaks in a huge amount of commission off the top
Ponzi scammers,
encourage investors to stay in the game for as long as possible in order to
maximize their profits. This ensures that plenty of money stays in the kitty.
There is very little in the way of real reporting of returns. At some point,
every Ponzi scheme,
it will collapse this sea that happens when the scammer decides to take the
money and do a runner or the cash dries up as it becomes more difficult to
attract more investors or too many people pull out and demand the principle and
the interest that's to be paid to them because of his auspicious,
standing in the trading world, Madoff was above suspicion for many years.
On top of this,
Bernie and Ruth had been huge political donors from 1991 onwards.
They weren't supporters of the democratic party,
given many thousands of dollars to the democratic senatorial campaign committee
members of the Madoff family.
They served in positions of authority in the security industries and financial
markets association.
S I F M a Bernie himself contributed some 56,000 to S I F M a in the two
thousands. In addition to the prestige of his position,
Bernie was extremely charismatic.
He came across as a person that people could trust.
When this was combined with his stellar reputation as a genius investor,
it was difficult for people to resist the temptation,
to invest their money with him. In fact,
during the two thousands people viewed it as a privilege to be given the
opportunity to invest with his firm.
Bernie was also careful not to set his promised interest rate to height.
He settled upon a rate of 12%,
which he found to be the perfect sweet spot to attract customers without raising
suspicion.
In 1992,
a couple of people who had invested in the success at AOL Al's accounting
company complained about irregularities to the us securities and exchange
commission.
The practice of drawing investors for Bernie had continued with the new owners
of this accounting firm. On this occasion,
the money was returned to these investors and no further action was taken in
1999. Harry Markopoulos,
the chief investment officer for options trading company,
Rampart investment management became aware that one of his companies major
trading partners was making investments with Madoff's wealth funds management
business and receiving constant of one to 2% per month.
Marco Opolis was asked to study Madoff's revenue stream in order to produce a
replica model, which would lure business away from Bernie and toward them.
According to Marco Opolis within four minutes of looking at Bernie's figures,
he knew that they were fake.
There was none of the price volatility that was fundamental to financial
investments. The interest rate reli to you was simply too good to be true.
He was convinced that Madoff was running a Ponzi scheme.
He laid a formal complaint with the S E and the spring of 2000, the S E however,
refused to take action. It seems they were just as spell bounds by Bernie,
as the investing public, but Marcopolis, he did not give up in 2001,
he forwarded a second more detailed complaint to the S E but once again,
the E S E C failed to take any action.
This despite Markos offering to go under coverings,
the made of operation to obtain concrete proof that Bernie wasn't actually
trading in 2004,
a lawyer for the security and exchange commission reported to her branch chief,
the, her investigation into the actions of Bernie Madoff raised a number of red
flags. However,
she was told in no uncertain terms to shut down her Madoff investigation and
focus on more important matters.
It just so happens that that senior official at the S E was involved in a
romantic relationship with Bernie's niece.
Shayna Madoff Madoff was able to keep the R going because invest,
it kept flowing in right through the mid two thousands. But then in 2008,
with the economy constricting the money pouring in,
it began to dry up with the stock market crash of September, the 29th,
the investment funds, they stopped up completely. What was worse.
People were demanding their money and their returns, but Bernie's account.
JP Morgan chase did not have the funds to pay them. He owed around 7 billion,
but only had between two and 300 million to pay out
By early December, 2008. Bernie knew that the game was up on December the ninth.
He told his brother Peter about his fraudulent activities. That same day,
he revealed to his son's mark and Andrew that he was finished.
And so that his whole life as a successful investment broker had been one big
lie. Bernie's sons immediately contacted a lawyer after leaving their father's
presence.
He put them in touch with the S E C two days later on December the 11th,
Bernie Madoff was arrested and charged with securities fraud.
He managed to come up with the 10 million bail and retain his freedom. However,
he was confined to house rest at his upper east side penthouse apartment,
and was under 24 hour monitor surveillance on March the 12th, 2009.
Bernie Madoff pled guilty to 11 federal felonies among them were securities
fraught, money laundering, and perjury.
He claimed that no one was involved with or knew about his crime,
which amounted to the largest Ponzi scheme in history at to that March the 12th
hearing judge Denny chin revoked Bernie's bail on the grounds that he was a
flight risk and had him thrown in the metropolitan correctional center.
His lawyers tried to get this decision revoked,
but they were unsuccessful as a result.
Bernie stayed in jail until his sentencing on June the 29th,
2009 trustees estimated that 36 billion was infested into Bernie's Ponzi
scheme. Half of that, it was returned to investors with the rest,
just going missing a week prior to sentencing Madoff's lawyer,
IRA Sorkin filed a pre-sentence letter to the judge requesting a term of 12
years for his client.
That was largely based on insurance industry estimates that his lifespan was
estimated to be a further 13 years.
The prosecution put in a request for 150 years imprisonment three days before
delivering a sentence.
Judge Chen ordered that 179 million worth of Bernie's assets are seized.
The bankruptcy trustee also sued Madoff sons, mark, and Andrew,
along with other family members for 198 million on the basis of negligence and
breach a fiduciary duty on June the 29th, 2009,
judge Chen delivered his sentence.
He followed through on the prosecution's recommendation and gave Madoff
150 years of jail time.
He noted at the time of delivering his sentence that they had not received any
mitigating factor letters or testimonies and commented that this absence of
support was telling at the time of his sentencing Madoff made the following
comment.
I have left a legacy of shame as some of my victims have pointed out to my
family and my grandchildren.
This is something I will live in for the rest of my life. I'm sorry.
Despite these words,
the judge did not believe that Madoff had been entirely forthcoming about the
details of his massive scam,
which chin referred to as ex brought a narrowly evil.
He also agreed with prosecutors that the Ponzi scam started long before the 1991
date that Bernie had given after the sentencing Ruthie Madoff made a first
public statement with the following words.
I am breaking my silence now because my reluctance to speak has been interpreted
as indifference or lack of sympathy for the victims of my husband Bernie's
crime, which is exactly the, of the truth.
I'm embarrassed and ashamed like everyone else, I feel portrayed and confused.
The man who committed this horrible fraud is not the man whom I've known for all
these years. Bernie was confined to the federal corrections Institute,
but medium outside of Butner, North Carolina, he remains there to this date.
It was reported in 2009 that he got into a fight with another elderly inmate.
However, the federal bureau of prisons denied this,
but said that he had been admitted to the hospital for hypertension as of 2009,
inmate 6 1 7 2 7 slash 0 54 is 81 years
of age. He scheduled for release on November the 14th, 2139,
at which time it'd be 200 and years of age.
So I hope you found that video. Interesting. If you did,
as always give us thumbs up below, why not subscribe?
Why not hit that bell button? So you actually find out when we put out videos,
that would be cool. The coolest of all would be, if you're checked out Nord VPN,
it helps support this show. It helps us making these four videos a week.
They're quite long. Like I say, our sponsors are super important.
So if you check them out, that would be amazing. And as always,
thank you for watching.